what are you hold on what do you got
nick dude this guy obviously has been up
for a couple days right here
yeah okay obviously randy quaid's son
uh hold on i feel so bad i'm already
judging this guy uh before he's even up
here
that that might be a good pick that
randy quaid son
and randy craig has had a birthday too
actually whose birthday
yup he does look like a little bit
that's good
we finally got one yeah yeah that's
brennan's really art really doing that
yeah um what's he saying
oh this episode is disgusting
[Laughter]
that's what i was what up brandon theo
coming to you from jackson tennessee on
the delivery truck
picking up them dirty laundries dropping
off them clean rags
got a king of the stinger for you gas
station food
king it or stinging snicker bars hitter
or big mac quitter
gang gang buzz buzz
if you don't have to worry about a diet
i don't mind that convenience store
food man you get the nachos you get that
weird
suspect chili on top of them nachos yes
suspect
here here's here's what's wrong
dude here's something real fast this is
disgusting i used to open up a bag of
doritos
and then put in the hot nacho cheese
yeah i do that with hot cheetos you
ain't
[ __ ] bro yeah that's oh that's the og
nothing but it's so nice yeah
what'd y'all do then you wash it down
with a nice rubber you get like the hot
cheetos or doritos
and you go to that cheese machine that's
for the for the nacho cheese
yeah you put them in that uh open up the
bag boom get that cheese what are y'all
doing science at the gas station you
guys are out of here
that was gold i looked dealing yeah
y'all paying for the cheddar or yeah
i'll tell them
usually i'd like what do you want for
the cheese like oh you got a dog they
just charged me for the chips
oh wow i put a little chili on there too
like a frito pie
see i used to know i had a dude that
used to work about a 7-11 by me and he
would text me and let me know whenever
they put the fresh franks up there on
the grill because some
on those rollers oh yeah you now they
got the pizza rollers on there too which
are [ __ ] fires
their taquitos are pretty good too well
no that's really good but
uh you got this thing back home called
quick trip they got real good guys
that's a gas station quick trip
started la crosse wisconsin baby hell
yeah
they employ like a third of the state
wow really
not a third of the state but they they
employ a lot of people uh they're
they're a great company like
great great employment benefits all that
like wow
yeah they take care of them i thought of
when i was growing up getting a job at
quick trip is unattainable
wow there's still time
[Laughter]
don't sell yourself short dude
yeah i love quick trips what is this guy
asking us about dirty laundry if you can
wear a nice shirt to a gas station
food gas station food basically i dig it
i dig it yes that's a great guy to know
the guy tipping you off about the fresh
dogs oh dude he would hit me up hey
hey you know we just put them all just
put them on cruise on down
there ain't nothing like a fresh dog oh
yeah and i like them the problem is you
get the ones that have been out there
three days four days
they're just percolating on those on
those rollers oh they're sitting
sideways
dude you know sideways yeah you'd see
them sweating they look all wrinkly
yeah and they put like almost one i
would have spf on it you're like how
long is this thing
someone sometimes they have them chatter
dogs too the big fat juicy chatter dies
rotate
come on nice
[Music]